[Musique]
il ya quelques jours j'étais un dîner
avec des amis et l'une des personnes
autour de la table s'est mis à part les
deux blocs chain alors j'étais curieuse
parce que ça fait maintenant un peu plus
d'un an que je travaille sur la blogo
chain et de ce dîner j'ai retenu deux
choses la première c'est que tout le
monde en avait déjà entendu parler et la
deuxième c'est que globalement personne
n'y avait rien compris alors c'est quoi
la blocs chaîne
cette question me la pose presque tous
les jours maintenant et la vérité c'est
qu'il ya plein de définition différente
alors je vais vous en donner une même si
vous allez voir la définition c'est
parce qu'il ya de plus important
la bio tchane c'est une technologie de
stockage et de transmission
d'informations qui est sécurisé et
transparente et qui fonctionne sans
organe central de contrôle
concrètement à quoi est-ce que ça
ressemble et bien une doctrine c'est un
registre qui contient des informations
des données des transactions et ces
informations vont être regroupées en
bloc
c'est pour ça qu'on appelle ça une
chaîne de blocs en anglais une block
chain et ce registre il a une
particularité c'est qu'il n'est pas
stocké sur un serveur central mais qu'il
est détenu par plein d'ordinateurs en
même temps le registre va donc être
stockées sur un grand nombre de serveurs
qu'on appelle les noeuds du réseau
et ça c'est très important parce que ça
le rend plus difficile à attaquer si
l'un de ces serveurs s'arrête de
fonctionner tous les autres continuent à
stocker le registre mais surtout la
bloque chaînes fonctionnent sans organe
central de contrôle
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'il n'existe pas une entité
centraliser une entreprise une personne
qui a la main sur le registre c'est un
algorithme qui va permettre à tous les
utilisateurs de se mettre d'accord sur
l'état du registre a intenté alors
généralement une fois que j'ai dit ça
les gens me regarde et me dise est alors
en quoi c'est une révolution
et bien c'est une révolution parce que
la blogo chain permet de s'échanger de
la valeur de pair à pair sans
intermédiaire et là vous allez me dire
oui mais le pair à pair ça existe déjà
avec internet notamment
et c'est vrai avec internet je peux vous
envoyer une information par email
directement de pair à pair sauf que
cette information elle sera dupliqué si
je vous envoie une photo par exemple
en fait je vous en envoie une copie vous
vous aurez accès à cette photo mais moi
aussi j'aurais toujours accès et ça ça
pose aucun problème lorsqu'il s'agit
d'une photo d'une vidéo d'information en
général mais ça pose un gros problème
lorsqu'il s'agit de valeur puisque si je
vous envoie 20 euros c'est très
important que moi je n'ai plus accès et
donc tout le pair à pair qui a été
rendue possible par internet trouve ses
limites lorsqu'il s'agit d'envoyer
quelque chose qui a de la valeur
qu'il s'agisse d'argent mais aussi de
points de fidélité de vote du billet
train d'actions etc
et donc aujourd'hui pour s'envoyer de la
valeur on a recours à de grands
intermédiaires des banques des
gouvernements etc
sauf que ces intermédiaires ils sont pas
parfaits dernier exemple en date il ya
quelques semaines au mois de novembre
le gouvernement indien a décidé du jour
au lendemain que les billets de 500 et
2000 roupies n'avaient plus cours
donc du jour au lendemain 80% de la
monnaie en circulation ne vaut plus rien
l'art à travers cet exemple on se rend
compte que ces grands intermédiaires en
qui on place notre confiance parfois
peuvent prendre des décisions qui ne
sont pas forcément dans notre intérêt
alors la question qui se pose donc c'est
ce qu'il n'y aurait pas un moyen pour
s'envoyer de la valeur sans ces
intermédiaires et c'est à cette question
qui a voulu répondre en 2008 une
personne dont on ignore toujours
l'identité et qu'on connaît sous le
pseudonyme satoshi nakamoto 2008 vous
vous en souvenez c'est la crise
économique le système bancaire vacille
les gens n'ont plus confiance en leurs
banques et satoshi nakamoto publie un
livre blanc
où il détaille le fonctionnement d'une
monnaie numérique qui fonctionne sans
banque une monnaie numérique pair à pair
cette monnaie numérique
il l'appelle bitcoin bitcoin aujourd'hui
si on cumule la valeur de tous les
jetons bitcoin en circulation ça vaut
plus de 11 milliards de dollars
bitcoin à un cours qui est établie par
l'offre et la demande
un bitcoin voit à peu près 700 euros et
c'est une monnaie qui n'appartient à
aucun pays à aucun gouvernement et a
aucune banque
elle appartient à tous ses utilisateurs
et pour faire fonctionner cette monnaie
numérique
satoshi nakamoto invente un protocole
informatique qui va permettre à tous les
utilisateurs de se mettre d'accord sur
l'historique des transactions qui ont
été faites en bitcoin et c'est ce
protocole sous jacent qu'on appelle la
bloque chain et effectivement cette
invention ali révolutionnaire pour
plusieurs raisons déjà parce qu'elle
permet un rééquilibrage de l'accès aux
ressources
elle permet à 2 milliards d'adultes non
bancarisés d'avoir accès à des services
financiers et de s'échanger de la
monnaie c'est d'ailleurs pour cette
raison qu'aujourd'hui 90% du volume de
transactions faites en bitcoin ont lieu
dans les pays en voie de développement
parce que dans ces pays c'est très
facile d'avoir un smartphone mais c'est
beaucoup plus difficile d'avoir un
compte en banque mais plus largement la
bloque chain bouleverse le transfert
d'argent supposant que tous ensemble on
va faire un virement pour un ami qui aux
états unis qui en a besoin demain matin
on s'est tous déjà comment ça va se
passer des gens les vendredis soirs donc
l'agent sera fermée ensuite ce sera un
rib américain donc ça mettra plus
longtemps bref c'est quasiment
impossible avec une banque classique ça
mettra des jours et en plus sûr à des
frais de transfert assez important et
bien avec la blocs chaînes notamment
avec bitcoin et mes autres crypto
monnaie je peux envoyer de l'argent à
l'international en quelques minutes et à
presque zéro frais mais la monnaie c'est
qu'une application de la bloque cheng
c'est la première c'est l'application
historiques notamment avec bitcoin mais
ce n'est pas la seule parce que si on
arrive à créer la confiance
entre des individus pour s'échanger de
la monnaie on arrive à créer la
confiance également sur d'autres
éléments premier exemple dans certains
pays en voie de développement
il est parfois extrêmement difficile de
prouver que vous êtes bien le
propriétaire de votre terre ou de votre
maison soit parce qu'il n'existe aucun
cadastre pour répertorier qui est
propriétaire de quoi soit parce qu'il
existe un cadastre mais qu'il est aux
mains de gouvernements instables qui
peuvent le modifier à leur guise
imaginez jour au lendemain quelqu'un
vienne chez vous et vous disent eh bien
non cette maison elle est à moi et vous
n'avez rien qui prouve le contraire
eh bien au ghana il existe une ong qui
s'appelle beat landes et qui a créé un
registre décentralisée fonctionnant sur
blog shane et permettant de certifier
l'existence de titre de propriété
et comme ce registre est distribuée et
bien personne ne peut décider
unilatéralement de le modifier
donc grâce à la bloquer non va permettre
à des individus de prouver de manière
plus efficace qu'ils sont bien les
propriétaires de leurs terres
deuxième exemple l'industrie de la
musique
si vous êtes un artiste vous créez une
chanson vous voulez la vendre sur une
plateforme de téléchargement ou de
streaming en général vous payer une
commission assez élevé de l'ordre de 20
à 30 % et un abonnement annuel
mais surtout votre rémunération
intervient en bout de chaîne c'est à
dire que la plateforme va d'abord
percevoir l'ensemble des revenus avant
d'en redistribuer une partie et vous
serez le dernier à être payés mais avec
la blogging on pourrait permettre aux
artistes de gérer leurs droits en temps
réel et d'être rémunéré automatiquement
dès lors qu'une oeuvre a été consommée
en gros dés qu'une chanson a été écouté
ou téléchargé et donc ça permettrait aux
artistes de reprendre le contrôle sur
leurs oeuvres
alors bien sûr il existe des
applications dans presque tous les
secteurs
on pourrait avec l'agglo chain créer des
communautés locales des changes
d'électricité pair à pair c'est par
exemple ce qui est en train d'être
expérimentée pas très loin d'ici à
confluence on pourrait avec la blood
chaîne et mieux protéger notre vie
privée
en redonnant aux citoyens le contrôle
sur leurs données personnelles
bref toutes ces applications qui sont
très utopique qui paraissent très
utopique sont bel et bien en train
d'être expérimentée et elle laisse
présager un nouveau monde
on pourrait sauter organisée grâce à la
technologie en se passant des
intermédiaires dans lesquels on n'aurait
plus confiance
et quelque part ça a du sens de préféré
faire confiance à un algorithme plutôt
qu'à un intermédiaire parce que
l'algorithme est moins subjectif parce
qu'il appartient à la communauté qui le
gère mais une fois qu'on a dit ça on
sorte quand même à pas mal de questions
on parle de suppression des
intermédiaires
mais aujourd'hui un algorithme ne peut
pas tout gérer la blocs shine peut
permettre de certifié l'existence de
titre de propriété
certes mais elle ne peut pas vérifier si
votre titre de propriété est authentique
puisqu'elle ne peut pas lire le document
elle peut pas venir chez vous vérifier
que vous êtes bien dans votre maison
vous en êtes bien le propriétaire
donc on peut déjà répondre à une
question qu'on me pose souvent non la
blocs chaîne à elle seule ne va pas
remplacer complètement les notaires et
puis la condition sinequanone pour qu'un
service existe c'est qu'il y ait
quelqu'un une communauté une entreprise
qui crée ce service on parle d'un über
sans über grâce à la bleue chain alors
effectivement on pourrait grâce à la
blocs chaîne automatisée des
transactions directes entre chauffeurs
et passagers sans passer par le compte
d'une entreprise centrale mais à un
moment donné
moi mon chauffeur je ne commande pas par
télépathie donc il faut bien qu'ils
aient un service qui me permet d'y
accéder
pareil si je veux faire des transactions
bitcoin effectivement je ne passe pas
par une banque mais se passe par une
plateforme de change qui me permet de
manière très intuitive très fluide
d'acheter des bitcoins ne les ait changé
et donc ce qu'on voit c'est que tous les
intermédiaires qu'on cherche à éliminer
avec la blood chaîne eh bien on les
recréer ailleurs et c'est d'ailleurs
pour cette raison qu'aujourd'hui de très
nombreuses grandes entreprises
s'intéressent beaucoup à la belote
chaîne
parce qu'elle y voit à la fois une
menace et une opportunité syllabes
l'obtiennent permet de faciliter les
relations entre individus
elle permet aussi de faciliter les
relations entre entreprises par exemple
sur une chaîne logistique complexe où il
y aurait de multiples partenaires ou
pour optimiser de relation contractuelle
et donc les entreprises vont chercher à
s'approprier cette technologie elles
vont créer des prototypes
bonsoir des consortiums parfois même
elles vont construire leur propre blog
shane est ce qu'on voit c'est que bien
souvent leurs démarches s'inscrivent
dans une logique incrémentale c'est à
dire qu'on ne discute pas tout d'un coup
on n'évolue pas à pas on transforme
lentement on s'approprie la technologie
et c'est là tout le paradoxe lablaude
shine au départ c'est pas une
technologie qu'on ajoute aux systèmes
existants
c'est un nouveau modèle à part entière
fondée sur le concept de transparence de
décentralisation de confiance donc il
faut pas croire que la bloque chain sera
la solution à tous les problèmes
on me demande souvent en quoi la blue
jam veut être utile at-elle secteur ou à
tel métier mais la bloquer n'a pas été
créé pour être utile à une catégorie de
secteur ou une catégorie de métiers
elle peut l'être mais à condition pour
certains de modifier radicalement leur
business model prenons une comparaison
début des années 90 2000 quand internet
s'est développé toutes les industries se
sont alors demandé comment elle allait
utiliser cette nouvelle technologie et à
l'époque l'industrie musicale s'est dit
créons des drm digital right management
pour empêcher tout le monde de partager
les chansons alors qu'il aurait très
bien pu créer des services innovants
comme deezer comme spotify
alors évidemment a posteriori c'est un
peu facile de dire ce qu'il aurait fallu
faire mais ce qu'on voit quand même à
travers cet exemple c'est que trop
souvent on cherche à utiliser la
technologie pour protéger les acquis
plutôt que pour les remettre en cause et
tout transformer en profondeur et bien à
l'instar d'internet dans les années 2000
l'abe l'obtiennent a le potentiel de
transformer radicalement
nos organisations et notre société et
donc la question qu'on doit se poser
maintenant c'est qu'est ce qu'on veut en
faire comment est-ce qu'on veut
transformer notre société
la blogueuse ce sera très probablement
l'infrastructure des échanges de demain
il est donc temps que chacun d'entre
nous prenne part à sa construction
que ce soit pendant notre temps libre
pendant notre travail ou même pendant un
simple dîner
merci
[Applaudissements]